huh different sector so much space
look you can see Edgar in left hey hey
hey hey say hey hello welcome to another
episode of the why
hence the beret let's just jump into the
memes I hate how he copyrighted let's
just jump into it can I not just say
let's just jump into it for no reason
what is this all my failed attempts for
allo I I'm giving up you made a gamer
you made it these are great I especially
like this one who is better
Marcia's fan art kids if it wasn't for
that other image just now I would say
yes that's a great dude that one of them
is incredible
like that's insane however the one on
the bottom it's got a distinct style
it's actually harder for an artist to
draw surrealistic instead of realistic
what the hell am I saying I was trying
to say she has to go from spot the fake
gamer video others voted her out and
looks like she's an OG 9 year old have
been subscribed to him since 2012 I've
seen enough I'm satisfied
thank you dear son alright official
announcement important announcement for
this channel I am watching Jojo season 2
apparently it's called part 3 why did no
one tell me that season 1 is so bad
compared to season 2 I would have just
skipped season 1 I missed out on so many
means it's not bad alright it's not bad
but man most studied languages at
duolingo in some countries Sweden
learning Sweden mass emigration everyone
how about that wait what that's it right
I think they say it even look up in the
sky it's a bird it's a plane it's
sponsor Eagle sponsor Eagle died of
leukemia I am so sorry to report this
I'm sure we can all move on petition to
add meteor animation to the Dino game
when it connect to the internet
right that's a pretty good fair thing I
like that idea good job Google
developers if you're watching go ahead
and do that you're welcome so how fast
can you click and me one view one like
well done that's how you know you're an
epic bro
not just bro whoever did this hug em
three two one zero
epic bro congratulations oh you are a
gamer name every truck good all right do
it we got the blue one and we got the
green one what can I say I'm a gamer
what can I say Nursery can catch us baby
and crib playing hockey what the hell
Canada we watch your career with great
interest
did you know that's a clone he's a clone
of Palpatine teacher before we start I
want to quickly thank our sponsor raids
shadow legends for sponsoring this class
I like that there's ads everywhere now
you can't escape it speaking of which
thank you nort I'm just kidding
today's video I have no sponsor this is
so sad actually chief you'll they get
cups by them 30% off on the G fuel if
you enter code peep I'd do it mate Sven
his best friend were killed by magma
block in suffocation his husband was
killed in a rollercoaster he had her
head son and son it's the same dog who
lives in hell
say hi to spin - - hey hey yeah yeah I
love it
Sookie bragging of that that's dope
that's dope I need to grow up hair again
hello hair where are you I think I'm
pretty close so I can start having hair
gel in my hair what do you guys think
I'm almost I'm almost there
I am almost there it's this setup just
confusing petition for peers to movies
face cam in part I already told sigh I
told them George Washington died in 1918
99 the first diner so Foster was
discovered in 1824 George Washington
never knew dinosaurs existed what that's
crazy
this changes everything could that mean
George Washington
so dinosaur yes PewDiePie it's all hate
s and it's very serious
not laughing matter hard do not pewds
making yo you're the theme for week the
yoga community me thinking him said
yo-yo we're making yo-yo and yo-yo it's
both gamers it's both oh god damn I just
got something in my throat it happened
at the store the other day I literally
got something in my throat and I
literally just went and everyone in the
line just went it's just a flu bro
it's just a flu bro
surprising my girlfriend with a hundred
thousand roses for this simp I never
thought I would say this about my man
mr. simple your sister B's I'm sorry
finally a week I can be part of god damn
eras
what people really out here doing yo-yo
Sh
dude sick well done well done that guy
got must get a lot of push straight up
made my whole Japanese toilet oh my god
that's amazing how much for you to
install one in my hump it's the only
thing I miss from July that's the thing
I miss the most from Japan how much it's
one of those toilet how much for
Japanese toilet it can't be that
expensive bright it's 400 pounds that's
cheaper than this chair that's just the
attachment isn't it I don't know I think
I'm still gonna have to go with this one
oh my god the father' continues I'm
worried this has been done already but I
wanted my own twist that's very nice
thank you
anxious hairball get a different name
please
oh it's mr. Haines Turkey fine
[Laughter]
my last resort is done
I don't think would have to come to this
20 million trees can we get a tree
update where you revisit and show how
the trees are doing
please mr. beast the B to the east
show us the treats I think I actually
got an email like a few minutes ago let
me check it
maybe they saw this meme and they
actually were like oh we need to update
people oh my god they did though behind
us we have a tree planting going on
[Music]
other weather-related incidents have a
lot of effect on how we manage the
forest and so often we need new plans
because the forest did not get as old as
it should have gotten young growing
forests keep planning those streets how
much done is selling a bracelet that
shocks you for Marty are you winning
Felix creating a six chamber and
minecraft yes it took me a while but I
got it because I minecraft did you guys
know I'm a gamer blue truck oh this is
so wrong if I was a female no one would
ask me if I was the gamer no one would
doubt it would you take a bullet for the
last person you had sex with Sven yeah
damn right
anything for a family cool there it is
it's so amazing look at my when you find
out that your normal daily lifestyle is
cold all right things to do in
quarantine
read a book time to read okay no more
should I do another book get a review
let me know in comments don't waste the
time just spending it on YouTube come on
do something productive 20/20 in every
ten seconds oh wait there's more I still
hate you
oh you pieces say that to my face in
garbage you trash the absolute subhuman
piece of that same officer that's the
guy that made his dog and
this is also quite comfortable I like
this oh my god oh my god it's the
beginning of the shrimp event no no oh
my god I'm glad people are actually
finally taking action and stocking up on
toilet paper essentials and
self-quarantine iing because the random
shrimp event is around the corner
basically at this point any given moment
it's here so we might stay humanity
might stand a chance after all what is
that shad PewDiePie found Terminator
pits holy Sh what a good boss what is he
doing Terminator boots isn't real
Oh God oh the meme just hit me as I
drank me playing Battlefield weird
there's no sound grandpa that's funny
trauma is always funny always 20/20
memes World War 2 uh-huh uh-huh April
random shrimp event it's it's not funny
don't joke about it this is serious
people are dead already probably who
knows we can't confirm China is probably
lying about sub not to get part what oh
my god game don't do that don't give me
hope that's pretty good impression you
got to give that to me
yet I got two more episodes coming right
up gamers I love playing it's so fun I'm
a gamer Felix will never get this okay
we'll see about that
uh I know what are we gonna I know what
are we gonna do today I know what are we
gonna do learn English and then you can
taught me about what I don't understand
yes I'm so hooked on this game dude I
think I'm close to hating it everyone
this says so much about our society I
got I will say this and I said this
before
toilet paper makes you really feel like
a Lycan savage like your inner ooga
booga land
when you're wiping your butt it makes me
feel I understand you do one safety wipe
after the bidet in Japan but in reality
I feel like a disgusting mud man if
we're wiping down there I shouldn't be
doing me I don't like it I don't think
it's okay I feel like it's one of those
things in the future they will tell the
kids in school be like yes
Timmy in the past they did actually wipe
their asses yes we toilet paper it's one
of those things future predictions Hey
PewDiePie 2020 80 I'm talking to you
Peter pie 2080 are you gonna be alive
that long no I'm not all right I think I
think it's pretty clear I need to make a
yo-yo video I think it's pretty clear
the time has come
stay off the trains they are only four
trains if you can read this you're not
the Train blind people choo choo blind
people be like choo choo nobody spends
on drawing his family it's not funny
don't laugh China permanently bans
consumption of wild animals you're about
two hundred and three thousand people
too late Ben Parker beloved husband and
uncle he turned into a pickle Uncle Ben
he would have loved it if who's the
funniest thing I've ever seen
can you believe George Washington never
knew but pickle rake that's crazy
everybody's talking about how pewds made
slender free-cos on the Sun but nobody's
talking about how Jack made ah what's
wrong with you jack apologize what's
wrong with you oh I like it
well done introverts after coming out at
self-isolation blending with the humans
get it I'm an introvert too god I forgot
to point that out how obnoxious
introverts are in my last video I'm an
introvert it's hard for me to blend in
I can't do public speaking because I'd
spontaneous myself oh yeah oh yeah
that's right I can do pen flip this is a
real reason I changed the camera people
born in March and April the coming weeks
oh my nephew is four years old had to
cancel his birthday party so sad in the
chat boys nobody pirates ah nah nah this
is small peepee I'm tired
learn to speak Maya Derek got him/her I
bet he's thinking about other women him
aerodynamics of Salix me same actually
that's why I fall asleep so happily
tonight I just think about how effective
my aerodynamics are in my haircut
all right so meme face guy pause Freddie
Mercury equals oh well isn't that great
there's a night just make you happy
another reason to sleep well at night
boys people's well done well done
Big B P energy right there well done
well done how old is PewDiePie 30 years
ok ok how long can you survive without
legs one is six hours okay all right
fair I think that's fair don't hurt
Swedish man in water we explode you know
and something of a Swede myself I
understand this meme now because I'm
gamer blue truck red truck gamer James
Bond or James Bourne Perry platypus god
damn what an absolute Chad right there
damn that's a cool thing right that's
sick
nice job you see him worthy art by
Arctic Monkeys up well done I'm Punk's
trama rebel I'm Asian side much like
Matt I dye my hair blah blah blah I'm an
intervention I must not have fun at
parties that's true already started
saving up for the apocalypse come on
everyone know what the new currency is
toilet paper we draw all your cash from
the bank do it now before it's too late
and then he calls himself pickle rack
alright gamers yo-yo week continues pose
yo yo yo memes thank you for watching
this episode smash like subscribe check
out the March hit the bell button do you
feel nice and I see you guys tomorrow
hey do you know what big pee pees do
they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course pixel ings is a creature
collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a Brazilian players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it
deal with it
you